big big companies from auto companies to
walmart 2-foot apparel companies like
Nike or coca-cola and food and beverage
and many others are now not only
thinking about this deeply but imposing
standards on all of their suppliers
which can number in the tens of
thousands and making requirements of
them to ship them less packaging less
waste more energy efficient less toxic
products and materials this does not
make them green companies this makes
that because I don't even know how to
define that we don't have a standard yet
for green company and nobody claims them
to be green including these companies
but but that means that they're they're
looking at both large and small things
and at the scale in which they operate
even small things can have a huge huge
impact give you just one little story
there's thousands of these a few years
ago McDonald's eliminated the embossed
golden arches on their napkins right
it's a little emboss school not just
probably know it no environmental
impacts of embossing that there's no you
know dot toxic dyes or heavy metals
maybe there's a little heat used in that
embossing process but what would happen
as a result well it made the napkins
24-percent thinner which means they can
fit twenty four percent more napkins in
a box twenty four percent more boxes in
a truck in a truck or tractor trailer
eliminating the need for shipping by the
equivalent of about a hundred tractor
trailers a year just from napkins now
that doesn't make McDonald's green
they're not green but the point is
they're doing hundreds and hundreds and
thousands of these things and so are
most companies out there we don't hear
about them they don't talk about them
you'd think that companies do in green
things in having significant impacts
would want to shout this stuff from the
rooftops but these in fact every company
wants green stories to tell everybody
feels they need to have one but the
reality is that green stories are hard
stories to tell for three reasons first
of all most of them are about doing less
bad right so if you have a widget in
this widget say hey this widget has
fifty-four percent fewer toxics than
last year that's a significant thing
from an environmental perspective but it
still means that hey we're beating our
wife forty-six percent of the time right
so that's not a very easy story to tell
however impactful it might be the
biggest reason is that a lot of these
things have no value to the to the
consumer in terms of the reason that
they buy a product so if anheuser-busch
would coca-cola if it figures out how to
bring out third of the aluminum in an
aluminum can which they've done over the
past decade or so and if you think of
that consider the environmental impacts
of mining bauxite to make aluminum or
the fact that manufacturing aluminum is
so energy intensive it's not one of the
top three or four or five greenhouse gas
amazing industries that's a significant
thing from an environmental achievement
but they're not going to put a green
seal on Bush and bud that's not why
people buy the stuff or if if if I
frito-lay I McDonald's or somebody who
makes potato chips you know sources
potatoes from a processor that now uses
closed-loop washing instead of flushing
the rinse water down the drain every
time they wash a load of potatoes they
now recycle it and use it over and over
filter it and you know and and all of
that saving hundreds of thousands maybe
millions of gallons of water a year
again a significant thing from an
environmental perspective but they're
not going to put a green label on a
holster fries or bag of potato chips so
it's these are things that you can't
always put on a hang tag or label or a
package or an advertisement but the
third reason is that when companies
start talking about what they're doing
right they often unwittingly illuminate
problems that the public didn't know
they had so a few years ago
I learned that that Levi Strauss which
at the time was the largest cotton buyer
in the world had started sourcing two
percent of their annual cotton by
organically and I thought that was a
really interesting story i called them i
wanted to write about it and they said
well we don't want to talk about it and
I persevered and I knew people there and
eventually I got them to talk with me
about it and of course one of the
questions I asked them was why don't you
want to talk about it they said well
look at it from our perspective when we
go out to tell this story we have to
explain why we're doing this first of
all that cotton is one of the hardest
crops to grow incredible and intensity
of pesticides and fertilizers and water
it's very hard to grow and and and and
then we have to talk about the impacts
of all that this pesticides and
fertilizers and the ground water runoff
and the impact on worker health and
safety and how that affects the birds
and the trees by the time we tell that
story we risk our customers saying so
you mean ninety-eight percent of what
you make is bad for people on the planet
why only two percent why not fight you
know we're going to do campus boycotts
so you commit to ten percent organic
cotton you can sort of hear that
conversation unfolding in the
marketplace and the conversation that
unfolded it Levi's is unfolding every
day at big companies which is to
basically ask the question do we do it
or do we talk about it or both and if we
talk about it how do we talk about it
I think it's a responsibility of
business to make products in a green way
and and make products that are perceived
to be responsible both in terms of the
products themselves and how the company
behinds them operate companies can only
go so far in terms of getting people to
eat well or exercise or or not abuse
their bodies in any number of different
ways and not abuse the planet as well
but there's a lot that companies can do
companies have tremendous communications
cloud and and a lot of companies i
talked to say well the customers
demanding that we're not hearing it from
the consumer will consumers buy lots of
things that they didn't demand it's
things that we make available to them
that we convince them that they want and
so there's an opportunity here to to
help promote a lifestyle that's a more
environmentally responsible probably
healthier for families and communities
as well but they have to as I said be
better products or perceived to have
some value beyond that now people want
to change without changing when it comes
to change people love the noun hate the
verb right so it's very hard for people
to really want to make dramatic changes
in their life unless they see some
specific and improvement for themselves
so the unfortunate part but it is the
reality is that when it comes to quote
unquote saving the planet it's really
about what's in it for me me first and
then the planet so I'm not going to make
a big change in my life I'm not going to
switch brands I'm not going to go out of
my way pretty much sir I'm not going to
pay any more for the privilege of doing
the right thing I have to get something
out of that and maybe it's just pride
maybe and some people do that maybe it's
a it's a badge of honor or maybe it's
just you know self-satisfaction but in
more cases not it has to be some
financial or performance or other kind
of benefit so I think to the extent that
companies can help us understand what
those benefits are and can in fact
design products and services that aren't
just greener but better there will be
opportunities here
one of the other realities is that
companies aren't very good at
storytelling around this stuff how many
steering really good at storytelling in
general but when it comes to the
environment storytelling takes on a
particularly important part of this do
you think about what we're talking about
here on one hand we're talking about
incredible complex geeky scientific
technical issues about which even the
experts don't always agree and on the
other hand we're talking about our
bodies and our and our families and our
kids in our community in our future and
our planet so its head and heart right
and if you've ever spent any time
talking to anyone about this you know
that if you go one millimeter too far in
either direction you lose your audience
or either you know to over your head I
don't know what you're talking about
this is just too complex for me or
you're too sort of California whoo-whoo
around this and you lose your audience
into your case and so storytelling is
how we integrate head and heart it's how
we we take complex things and make them
accessible companies haven't done a very
good job of doing that you know there's
this line that's just you know I don't
but I just take Kermit you'll know
exactly what the line is it's it ain't
that easy being green is the song lyric
that Kermit sang you know how long ago
that was 41 years ago 1969 it's older
than Earth Day and and that still
represents the state of the art of green
marketing I get press releases every day
Commons pitches advertising slicks all
kinds of things from copywriters and ad
agencies and PR firms and the like and I
know that the person that contain that
Kermit line or some version of it is it
isn't that easy and I know that the copy
writer who wrote that thinks that she or
he is the most clever person for having
come up with that and the fact is it's
tired it's it's hackneyed and it's not
even true it's not that easy being green
it actually takes some work so we need
to find better ways to communicate and
tell those stories
you know in the in the 1990s during the
dot-com boom of the late 90s there was
this this axiom that that content is
king that those companies that had
content would be the ones that ruled the
universe in the new connected digital
internet world and a lot of those
companies most of them went away and it
turns out that it wasn't content that
was king it was context context is king
and if you look at the companies that
survived the ebays and Google's and
Yahoo's and and and others those are the
ones that in craigslist and those are
the firm's that make sense of all this
massive information out there they give
it some kind of context i'm a bility to
organize and find things and and have
things elevate to what the things are
the most important of all and relative
to your interests or relative to that of
your friends and and so in context is
what's missing here in terms of company
storytelling they want to know that
something is good or better for the
environment they went out of the context
because if you say well this is green
and therefore you should buy it so well
how green and what is it really green or
has it is it part of is it the only
issue this product has is that is your
you company as a company trying to say
you're green as a result of that so I
think people want to know that you
understand as a company what your
environmental issues are they want to
know that you know your problems that
you've done your homework and then they
want to know that you're on the case
that you're doing something about that
that you've got some plan in some kind
of commitment and that you have some and
that you're talking about this openly
and authentically not just waving your
arms and and quoting Kermit and saying
hey we green but actually putting it
into context and giving it some some
sense of this is what we're doing right
now but this is part of a journey that
we're on this is part of a long-term
proposition we're not claiming that by
doing this we're a green company I think
that people who who the companies that
can demonstrate that they understand
their problems from an environmental
perspective have a plan in place to do
something about it even if its long-term
and imperfect and never gets them to be
perfectly good which no company really
ever will be and are talking about that
openly and authentically will be in
I laid a foundation for being able to
make specific environmental claims and
and put out environmental products and
talk about environmental issues in a
credible way and not and even to
innovate and fail and still land on
their feet and not be charged as green
washers or as phonies or just ignored
and I think that companies don't lay
that foundation they don't create that
context that they need in order to make
specific environmental claims